.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
In Simplon Dorf haben wir
fast alles. - Nein, etwas fehlt.
Wir suchen einen neuen Lehrer
oder eine neue Lehrerin.
Bitte helft uns.
Dieser digitale Hilferuf aus
Simplon Dorf ging im Frühling viral.
Es war ein letzter Versuch,
eine Nachfolge für den
scheidenden Primarlehrer zu finden.
Der kleinen Bergschule
drohte sogar die Schliessung.
Doch dann kam sie:
Ich bin Sara Zwahlen und ich bin
die neue Lehrerin von Simplon Dorf.
Ich habe hier oben meinen Traumjob
und meine Traumschule gefunden.
Für das 295-Seelen-Dorf
ist die Schule wichtig,
denn sie kann verhindern,
dass junge Familien wegziehen.
Primarlehrerin Sara Zwahlen hat sich
bis im Frühling verpflichtet.
Bis dann springt sie
für die definitive Lehrperson ein.
Ich freue mich richtig.
Sie sind so lebendig
und alles wirkt so friedlich.
Ich freue mich riesig.
Den Kindern
bleibt die Hin- und Rückfahrt
zur Schule nach Brig erspart.
So haben sie mehr Freizeit.
Der Lehrer und die Eltern
sind erleichtert.
Denkt man darüber nach,
nach Simplon Dorf zurückzukommen
und es hat keine Schule hier,
ist der Entscheid schon gefallen.
Wir sind sehr dankbar,
dass es wieder eine Schule hat.
Primarlehrer Escher
zeigt Sara sein Reich.
Scarlett,
das ist deine neue Lehrerin.
Nach dem Sommer
kommst du dann zu mir.
Schön.
Hast du schon mal Schule gemacht?
Nein, ich komme frisch vom Studium.
Ich habe ein Praktikum gemacht,
aber ihr seid meine erste Klasse.
Wolltest du schon mal
nicht in die Schule gehen?
Also, nicht mehr in die Schule,
um zu lernen?
Irgendwann machte mich mein Lehrer
sicher auch wütend.
Irgendwann dachte ich auch,
dass ich nicht mehr gehen möchte.
Aber dann gab es immer
eine positive Überraschung.
* Fröhliche Melodie *
Die Schülerinnen und Schüler besuchen
die dritte bis fünfte Primarklasse.
Es ist
ein gemischtstufiger Unterricht.
Aber es gibt einiges,
das sie gemeinsam machen können -
wie das Flötenspiel.
Damit überraschen sie Sara,
die frisch von der
Pädagogischen Hochschule kommt.
Bravo, sehr schön.
Darf man applaudieren?
Schön.
Ich habe nicht erwartet,
dass ich so ein Konzert kriege.
Das ist sehr positiv, wirklich.
Die Schuhe werden immer grösser.
Ich muss mich
über den Sommer gut vorbereiten.
Drei Generationen Dorfkinder
hat Lehrer Escher unterrichtet.
Jetzt verabschiedet er sich
in die Frühpension.
Nach 39 Jahren ist man auch froh,
etwas anderes zu machen.
Ich habe so viele Jahre
immer nach einem Stundenplan gelebt.
Jetzt einen anderen
oder keinen Stundenplan zu haben,
ist mir auch recht.
Ich will Dinge machen, die ich
bis jetzt vernachlässigt habe.
Bis jetzt konnte ich mich
zu Hause an den Tisch setzen
und dann kam das Essen.
Vielleicht sollten meine Frau
und ich mal die Rollen tauschen -
ich koche
und sie kann sich bedienen lassen.
Sara
stammt aus dem St. Galler Rheintal.
Sie war erst einmal hier oben.
Der Schulleiter
begleitet sie durchs Dorf.
Ich bin gespannt.
Das ist der Lebensmittelladen.
Genau.
Der Dorfladen
bietet allerlei Lebensmittel
für den täglichen Bedarf an.
Er ist auch Papeterie und Bücherei.
Und v.a. ist er
d i e  Informationsbörse im Dorf.
Und 85 Rp.
- Merci vielmals.
Bitte.
Kannst du das so nehmen?
- Tipptopp.
Ich ging heute um 8 Uhr aus dem Haus
und wollte zwei Sachen holen.
Es ist bald 9.30 Uhr
und ich bin immer noch unterwegs.
Man trifft immer wieder jemanden.
Bei schönem Wetter spazieren alle
rum und machen ihre Einkäufe.
Ich bin seit anderthalb Stunden
unterwegs,
wollte aber nur schnell Brot
und Butter fürs Frühstück holen.
Älteren Menschen werden die Einkäufe
nach Hause geliefert.
Das lokale Gewerbe zu unterstützen
habe noch weitere Vorteile.
Es sind 30 km nach Brig
oder 30 km nach Domodossola.
Da muss man die Rechnung
selber machen:
Nehme ich den Einkaufsweg auf mich?
Die Autofahrt
ist ja auch nicht gratis.
Für das Geld,
das man mit dem Auto ausgibt,
könnte man hier auch gut einkaufen.
Schulleiter Ewald Walker
zeigt Sara ihre zukünftige Wohnung.
Die Gemeinde hat sie ihr vermittelt.
Ah, wow, gross.
- Schön.
Sozusagen als Bonus
schenkt ihr die Gemeinde
die Wohnungsmiete
bis zum Wegzug Ende Februar.
Den Balkon muss ich auch noch sehen.
Der ist ja gross.
- Ja.
So schön.
(Frau) Hallo.
- Grüezi. Hallo.
Freundliche Nachbarn.
- Genau.
Für mich ... Ich hatte bisher
keine eigene Wohnung.
Und jetzt kriege ich
so eine Hammerwohnung mit Balkon,
so einer tollen Aussicht
und Nachbarn, die schon Hallo sagen.
Traumhaft. Wirklich schön.
Simplon Dorf liegt auf 1'476 m
auf der Südseite des Passes.
Nur gerade 295 Menschen leben hier.
Die idyllischen alten Häuser
mit Steindächern
sorgen für italienisches Flair.
Aber das Dorf hat ein Problem:
Die Einwohnerzahl sinkt.
In den letzten sechs erfassten Jahren
sind 65 weggezogen -
wegen der Arbeit oder der Ausbildung.
Nur 36 sind zugezogen.
Hier gibt es weder Arzt
noch Apotheke.
Ein Auto ist ratsam.
Sebastian Arnold ist seit
viereinhalb Jahren Gemeindepräsident.
Diesen Nebenjob konnte er nicht
ablehnen, denn hier gilt Amtspflicht.
Der Ingenieur
will das Dorf modernisieren.
Nur so könne es überleben,
ist er überzeugt.
Das ist ein grosses Spannungsfeld.
Was soll erhalten bleiben?
Was soll man
in die Zukunft mitnehmen?
Wo braucht es einen Neuanfang?
Das ist sehr schwierig.
Arnold hat eine Vision:
Er will auf Elektromobilität
und Homeoffice setzen.
Das soll helfen, Zuzüger anzulocken.
Auch die Post und den Dorfladen
will er zusammenlegen.
Aber für fast jede Veränderung
muss er bei den Einheimischen
Überzeugungsarbeit leisten.
Was können wir machen ...
... wenn sie das Büro schliessen?
Die Pakete kann man im Dorfladen
abgeben - und alles andere?
In dieses Hotel soll der Dorfladen
mit integrierter Post umziehen.
Das sei kostengünstiger
und effizienter, sagt Arnold.
Man würde das Restaurant
als Burgergemeinde aufgeben
und dadurch dem Dorfladen
Fläche schaffen.
Die oberen Hotelzimmer würde man als
sog. Self-Check-in-Hotel betreiben.
Die Gäste kann man durch
die übrigen Betriebe verpflegen -
sei es durch das Restaurant
oder die Bäckerei.
Das ist spannend.
Wir sehen grosse Möglichkeiten
und eine grosse Wertschöpfung
für das Dorf.
Wir lassen Licht ins Schulzimmer.
Neuzuzügerin Sara Zwahlen
nutzt die Sommerferien,
um ihr Schulzimmer einzurichten.
Viel Grün gehört dazu, schliesslich
ist sie gelernte Floristin.
Die muss ich irgendwie festmachen.
Hoppla.
Du willst jetzt
genau nicht dableiben.
Aber so liegst du besser.
Nein.
Man kann sie in Wasser setzen
und dann wächst sie wieder.
Sie ist momentan kaputt ...
... aber sie wächst ja wieder.
Es hat vieles, das mehr
an einen Dschungel erinnert
statt an ein Bergdorf.
Ich dachte mir, dass es anfangs
halt einen Lerndschungel gibt.
Es muss etwas mehr Abenteuer haben.
Ihre eigene Abenteuerlust zog sie
früh nach England und Norwegen,
im Frühling lockt Kanada.
Das Fach Umwelt
ist für Sara ein wichtiges -
genauso wie Ökologie
und Nachhaltigkeit.
Klimaerwärmung ist momentan
unser aktuellstes Thema.
Man kann sehr gut
mit den Kindern darauf eingehen.
Was ist Nachhaltigkeit?
Wie gehen wir mit dem Planeten,
mit unseren Ressourcen um?
Was kann ich machen?
Wie kann ich die Erde
und unsere Natur schützen?
Es fängt ja immer
bei einem selbst an.
Sara ist gerne und oft in der Natur.
Diese
zieht auch viele Tagesausflügler an.
Biken, Wandern und Klettern
im Sommer,
Skitouren im Winter.
Doch am Abend fahren
die meisten wieder hinunter ins Tal.
Roswitha Escher betreibt das Hotel
Fletschhorn in fünfter Generation.
Sie hat noch die goldenen Zeiten
der Italienreisenden erlebt.
Damals mussten die Sonnenhungrigen
hier oben tanken
und ihrem Auto und sich selber
eine Pause gönnen.
Doch die Geschichte des Tourismus
reicht noch viel weiter zurück.
Das ist das alte Gästebuch
des Hotels Fletschhorn.
Es startet 1910 und man sieht,
dass es von 1910 bis 1930/40 viele
internationale Touristen hatte.
V.a. aus den USA,
aber auch aus England.
Es hat ein paar aus Russland, es hat
Franzosen, Italiener und Deutsche.
Das sind eigentlich die Gäste,
die uns jetzt fehlen.
Der internationale Nord-Süd-Verkehr
hat sich in den letzten
20, 30 Jahren verändert.
In den 70er-Jahren fuhren die Leute
vom Norden in den Süden ans Meer.
Der Simplonpass
war der letzte Stopp vor Italien.
Somit hatten wir
sehr viele internationale Gäste.
Viele Wohnungen im Dorf werden
nur während der Ferienzeit genutzt.
Das verknappt den Wohnraum
für die Ansässigen.
Doch Familie Molinari hatte Glück.
Sie kaufte sich
dieses 400-jährige Hauptmannshaus.
Fabian Molinari zog es nach einigen
Jahren als Grenzwächter in Genf
und
Botschaftsangestellter in Moskau
wieder in die Heimat zurück.
Ich sortiere gerade
die alten Holzäxte aus.
Es ist egal, welche man nimmt:
Jede hat so ihre Geschichte.
Mit jeder
wurde etwas anderes gemacht.
Die Heimat und das Alte
faszinieren mich -
weil so viel Geschichte drinsteckt.
Molinari
führt eine Metzgerei in Brig.
Hier oben hat er eine alte Tradition
zu neuem Leben erweckt:
die Herstellung
von getrocknetem Schinken.
Die Bergluft verleihe dem Fleisch
einen intensiven Geschmack.
Ja, der ist reif.
Das funktioniert. Das hat schon in
den letzten 100 Jahren funktioniert.
Ich versuche jetzt,
das weiterzuziehen.
Ich verwende nur Salz -
wie anno dazumal.
Schweizer Fleisch
und die trockene Luft hier.
Wir haben
um die 55 % Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Das eignet sich gut dazu,
das Fleisch zu trocknen.
Und das Klima selber ...
Es kommt alles zusammen.
Das Paket stimmt.
Früher war diese Methode
der Fleischkonservierung
im ganzen Dorf verbreitet.
Auch die Dorfsennerei
will Traditionelles
mit Neuzeitlichem verbinden.
Buongiorno.
- Buongiorno.
Un po' di formaggio di raclette.
- Si.
In fette?
- Si, grazie.
Liliane Arnold hat im Sommer die
Sennerei von ihrem Onkel übernommen.
46 Jahre lang
hat er sie allein geführt.
Der preisgekrönte Raclettekäse
ist ein Renner.
Für ihn kommt die Kundschaft
sogar aus Mailand.
Bei uns
gibt es keine eigene Sennerei mehr.
Diesen Käse gibt es sonst nirgends.
Doch, im Supermarkt.
Aber der hier ist viel besser.
Cosí?
- Si, si, va bene.
Die ausgebildete Milchtechnologin
hat vier Helfer angestellt
und den Betrieb digitalisiert.
Trotzdem
arbeitet sie über 12 Std. täglich.
Früher gab es viel mehr Bauern,
aber weniger Milch.
Jetzt ist es eher umgekehrt:
weniger Bauern
und mehr oder gleich viel Milch.
Wir sind noch sieben Landwirte,
die Milch liefern,
aber wir haben gleich viel Milch
wie vor zehn oder 15 Jahren.
Grazie. Arrivederci.
- Arrivederci. Ciao.
* Kirchenglocken *
Der Sommer verabschiedet sich
und mit ihm auch die Touristen.
Die Ferien sind zu Ende.
Das neue Schuljahr wird
mit einem Gottesdienst begangen -
wie eh und je.
Der erste Schultag ist für die Kinder
u n d  die Lehrerin
etwas ganz Besonderes.
Ich bin gespannt
und etwas angespannt, nervös.
Ich hatte komische Träume.
Einmal schrak ich auf
und musste noch mal kontrollieren,
ob ich für heute
nichts vergessen habe.
Dann war es wieder gut.
Ihr habt sicher viel zu erzählen.
Das ist der Quatschball.
Jeder kriegt ihn einmal
und kann von seinen Ferien erzählen.
Ich habe euch um etwas gebeten.
Könnt ihr das mal rausnehmen?
Ich habe diese Lampe mitgenommen.
Die haben wir selber gemacht.
Wenn man sie brennen lässt,
leuchtet sie in der Nacht.
Auch ein treuer Begleiter.
Der hat schon vieles gesehen.
Sehr schön.
Wenn ich in den Ferien wandern
ging, nahm ich fast immer den mit.
Damit sammelte ich Heidelbeeren
und ging hirten.
Dieses Schiff kriegte ich
auf dem Kreuzfahrtschiff.
Das Schiff war 337 m lang
und 42 m breit.
Dieses Stofftier kam mit,
als ich nach England zog,
als ich in Norwegen wohnte,
und jetzt natürlich auch
bei meinem Umzug nach Simplon.
Es ist schön, wenn man
ein Kissen hat, das man schon kennt
und das einem vertraut ist.
Ein Chischi?
- Ein Kissen. Sag es noch mal, Finn.
Ein Chischi.
- Ah, okay, ein Chischi.
Ein Kissen, ja.
Die Wunschzettel der Kinder
für das neue Schuljahr
sehen wohl ähnlich aus
wie überall auf der Welt:
viel Spass, keine strenge Lehrerin
und coole Turnstunden.
Ich lese das über Mittag durch
und am Nachmittag
sehen wir es uns an, ist das gut?
(Alle) Ja.
Ist es so,
wie Sie es sich vorgestellt haben?
Besser.
Ich fragte mich,
ob sie direkt erzählen würden
oder ob sie eher scheu
und zurückhaltend sein würden.
Aber sie gehen darauf ein
und machen mit.
"Am Samstag und Sonntag
keine Hausaufgaben zu haben".
Diesen schönen Wunsch
kann ich schon mal erfüllen.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Einige Wochen später
stehen die Herbstferien vor der Tür.
Einmal mehr
ist Sara früh im Klassenzimmer.
Die ersten drei Wochen war ich
schon um 6.15 oder 6.30 Uhr hier.
Das war noch die Nervosität
der ersten zwei Wochen.
Aber es wird immer entspannter.
Ich schlafe gut.
7 Uhr ist meine Richtzeit.
Um 7 Uhr in der Schule ist gut.
Pro Stufe muss Sara
32 Lektionen vorbereiten.
Ich darf halt
drei Klassen unterrichten.
Sie sind auf verschiedenen Niveaus
in den Sprachen und in Mathe.
Für NMG
kann man sie gut zusammennehmen.
Da helfen auch die Grossen gut mit
und erklären es den Kleineren.
Den Kindern gefällt es
und sie arbeiten mit.
That's okay.- Was er mag,
nicht, was er nicht mag.
But he loves music, so it's okay.
And he hates sports.
Also, wenn er Sport hasst,
hasst er das ja.
So, "I hate" heisst was? Camila?
"Ich hasse."
- And "I love"?
"Ich liebe."
- Genau.
Saras Nachfolgerin
ist aus England angereist.
Sie will sich ein Bild vom Dorf und
ihrem zukünftigen Arbeitsort machen.
Hier ist das Lehrerzimmer.
Hier ist das neue Klassenzimmer.
* Lachen *
Guten Morgen zusammen.
Vielleicht hat Sara schon gesagt,
dass heute Frau Widmer
zu Besuch ist.
Sie ist ab März eure neue Lehrerin.
Ich bin Frau Widmer.
Ich wohne zurzeit in England.
Ich wohne seit zehn Jahren dort.
Im März ziehen wir zurück
in die Schweiz, nach Simplon Dorf.
Ich bin heute das erste Mal hier.
Wir sehen uns nachher das Dorf
etwas an und lernen alles kennen.
Ich würde gerne von euch erfahren,
wer ihr seid, was ihr gerne macht
und was nicht so.
(Sara) Name?
- Ich bin Finn.
Ich fahre gerne Velo und Ski.
Und ja ... Nicht gerne ...
Ich fahre nicht so gerne Trottinett.
Ich bin Camila und ich mag
Schwimmen, Skifahren, Velofahren,
Bobfahren und Scooterfahren.
Und Französisch, Deutsch und Mathe
mag ich nicht so.
Danke vielmals,
dass ihr mir etwas erzählt habt.
(Sara) Dann dürft ihr
euren Tee trinken. Lüftdienst.
Cornelia Widmer ist der Liebe wegen
vor zehn Jahren
nach England ausgewandert.
In einer Kleinstadt unterrichtet sie
eine Klasse mit 30 Kindern.
Hier wird sie nur noch sechs haben.
Das war eine lustige Geschichte:
Während des ersten Lockdowns
waren die Schulen in England
monatelang geschlossen.
Ich musste meine Kinder fast ein
halbes Jahr zu Hause unterrichten
und genoss die Freiheit
und fand das gemütlich.
Ich sagte meinem Mann,
er solle sich vorstellen,
dass ich dafür bezahlt werde.
Das wäre der Traumjob.
Vielleicht
mit ein paar Familien mehr,
damit die Kinder
nicht so allein sind.
Kurz darauf sah ich dieses Video
von Simplon Dorf
und fand, das sei doch genau das.
Die Kinder
sind Sara ans Herz gewachsen.
Sie mag noch nicht
an den Abschied denken.
Ich freue mich natürlich für sie.
Sie kommt in ein perfektes Umfeld.
Es ist wirklich cool.
Für mich ist es komisch,
aber ich wusste das ja.
Ich hatte mich darauf eingestellt.
Das war von Anfang an so abgemacht
und das ist auch in Ordnung.
Auf Familie Widmer
kommen grosse Veränderungen zu.
Ich habe zwei Jungs,
die fünf und sieben sind.
Das ist Finbar.
Er wird im Januar acht.
Und das ist Thorben. Er ist fünf.
Sie sprechen hauptsächlich Englisch,
verstehen aber
ein bisschen Schweizerdeutsch.
D.h.,
ihr müsst ihnen etwas helfen, okay?
Eine Lehrerin, die hierherzieht
und erst noch Mann
und zwei Schulkinder mitbringt.
Besser kann es für den
Gemeindepräsidenten gar nicht kommen.
Er begleitet Cornelia Widmer
und ihren Ehemann persönlich
zur Wohnungsbesichtigung.
- Am Samstag war es sehr warm.
Um zu wandern und von der Natur her
ist Herbst eine schöne Zeit.
Wie ist es Ende Februar?
Hat es dann noch viel Schnee?
Ende Februar sind wir
noch komplett im Schnee.- Wirklich?
Der englische Ehemann
wirkt noch etwas zurückhaltend.
Alles ist völlig anders als bisher.
Typisch Schweiz.
Sehr nett, gutes Wetter ...
Yeah.
In welchem Stock ist sie?
- Zuoberst.
Okay.
Widmers
könnten Saras Wohnung übernehmen -
falls sie ihnen zusagt.
Kommt rein.
- Merci. Hier wohnst du?
Ja.
(Cornelia)
Wow, sieh dir die Aussicht an!
(Sara) Das ist die Küche.
Die Küche ist etwas kleiner.
Du kannst nur hier etwas verstauen.
Ja, da hat es relativ wenig Platz.
Okay.
(Sara) Hier ist es auch megaschön.
- Wieder diese Aussicht.
It's alright with the two balconies,
isn't it?- Mhm.
Die Küche ist relativ klein
und Sara hat gerade gesagt,
es sei relativ hellhörig.
Das könnte ein Problem sein.
Die Kinder sind es nicht gewohnt,
Rücksicht nehmen zu müssen.
Während seine Frau unterrichtet,
wird Jim den Haushalt managen.
Aber er ist skeptisch.
Zwei Jungs,
ein Hund und alles andere,
was wir aus England hierherbringen.
Ich versuche, mir das vorzustellen.
Wir ziehen von einem Haus
in eine Wohnung.
Diese Wohnung ist zu klein.
Gut kann ihnen der Gemeindepräsident
noch eine grössere anbieten.
Der Umzug von einem Haus
in eine Wohnung
und der Wechsel
von einem urbanen Umfeld
in die dörfliche Abgeschiedenheit
sind nicht einfach.
Eine Dorfgemeinschaft
kann bei der Integration helfen.
In der Schulküche
werkelt seit dem frühen Sonntagmorgen
der Klub der kochenden Männer.
Auch Architekt Andrea Catanese
ist mit von der Partie.
Ich habe einen etwas undankbaren
Job, aber jemand muss ihn machen.
Einfach aufräumen.
Wie wichtig ist so ein Klub
für ein Dorf?
Sehr wichtig, finde ich.
Im Verein kommen Leute zusammen,
die sonst
im normalen, täglichen Ablauf
wenig miteinander zu tun hätten.
Wir sehen das Spektrum hier:
von Urs, der über 60 ist -
keine Ahnung, wie alt genau -
bis zu Leuten Ende 20 -
alles ist vertreten.
Vom Familienvater bis zum Ledigen -
Leute, die sonst
nicht viel zusammen zu tun hätten.
Die 16 Hobbyköche sind gefordert.
Zusammen mit Freiwilligen
bereiten sie ein mehrgängiges Menü
für über 100 Personen zu.
Auch Sebastian Arnold hat sich die
Schürze umgebunden und packt mit an.
Unser Chefkoch
hat das Menü zusammengestellt.
Es ist sicher etwas Interessantes.
Wir machen einen Dreigänger.
Zuerst präsentieren wir den Leuten
eine Weissweincremesuppe.
Danach
gibt es Butternudeln mit Gemüse,
dazu ein Schweinsnierstück
mit einer Pilzsauce
und als Dessert
gibt es eine Kirschen-Pannacotta.
Vereine sind ein wichtiges
soziales Bindemittel.
Im Dorf gibt es 23 davon.
Gleich neben der Schulküche
hat die Musikgesellschaft Bleiken
in der Turnhalle zum Lotto geladen.
Nummer 20.
- Hier.
Klara kann nach Leukerbad.
* Applaus *
Aber nicht nur ins Bad,
sondern auch Ski fahren.
Was haben Sie gewonnen?
- Einen Eintritt nach Leukerbad.
Das ist wunderbar.
Meine Schwester wohnt in Leukerbad.
Das geht dann gut zusammen.
Als Nächstes kommt ein Gutschein
für zwei Walliser Teller
im Restaurant Fletschhorn
in Simplon Dorf.
Den gewinnt Nummer 756.
- Hier!
Nummer 756.
* Applaus *
Ich gewinne ab und zu was.
Was haben Sie denn schon gewonnen?
- Meine Frau.
* Lockere Musik *
Der Erlös des Losverkaufs
geht an die Musikgesellschaft.
Sie setzt das Geld für die
Anschaffung neuer Instrumente ein.
Haben die Leute ein System dafür,
welche Karten sie nehmen?
Nein, sie machen es aufs Geratewohl.
Gewisse sagen,
ich solle ihnen eine Karte geben.
Aber das mache ich nicht.
Wenn sie nicht gewinnen,
bin ich schuld.
235.
235 hier im Saal.
* Applaus *
Ein solcher Anlass
zieht auch die Weggezogenen an.
Ich war ein paar Jahre
als Schlagzeuger im Musikverein,
aber jetzt doch schon
seit fünf Jahren nicht mehr.
Darum dachte ich,
es sei ein guter Zeitpunkt,
um zurückzukommen,
den Verein zu unterstützen
und hoffentlich
ein paar Preise abzuholen.
Aber v.a. geht es darum,
den Verein zu unterstützen.
Sie sind weggezogen?
- Ja, genau.
Ich bin jetzt am Thunersee,
in Oberhofen.
Aber die Verbindung zu Simplon Dorf
bleibt bestehen,
darum komme ich auch gerne zurück.
(Alle) Whoo!
* Lockere Musik *
Es hilft auch,
den Heimatstolz
in der Bevölkerung etwas aufzubauen.
Wenn es einen Event gibt,
helfen alle mit.
Alle leisten ihren Teil.
Das gibt
ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl,
das durch die Vereine sicher
stark wächst und unterstützt wird.
Auch die Kinder bekommen
dieses Gefühl schon früh zu spüren.
Sara Zwahlen hat in den
vergangenen Monaten Kontakte geknüpft
und neue Bekanntschaften geschlossen.
Und ihre Zukunftspläne geändert.
Ich gehe jetzt
vier Monate nach Kanada.
Vier Monate?
Und dann fange ich
einfach wieder im Wallis an.
In den Schulen Brig Süd?
Ja, Ewald sagte, er schaue,
ob es unten in Brig oder in Termen
etwas hat.
Ja.
- Je nachdem. Mal schauen.
Hauptsache,
ich kann im Wallis bleiben.
Bei diesem Topwetter.
- Ja.
Hat Sie das Wallis also gepackt?
- Ja, ich bleibe hier.
Was ist so faszinierend am Wallis?
Die ganze Landschaft.
Ich fühle mich einfach megawohl,
auch hier im Dorf.
Alle sind superlieb und ich konnte
schon überall Leute kennenlernen.
Ich gehöre auch
zu einer Klettergruppe.
Ja.
Doch, ich bleibe.
* Lockere Musik *
Sara wird wohl vom Bergdorf
in die Stadt ziehen -
so, wie die meisten.
Und der Gemeindepräsident
wird weiterhin weibeln müssen,
damit Simplon Dorf eine Zukunft hat.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021